juste vous dire ça y apparaît comme une
lettre à philippe qui m'a écrit il m'a
écrit alors il s'agit d'un fan non
philippe qui écrit très souvent à la
production pour que j'en vois une photo
dédicacée mes soucis c'est que j'ai pas
eu les lettres et j'ai uniquement la
dernière où il à dire toutes les fois où
il a écrit et il a écrit julie juillet
2013 25 janvier 2014 à 2015 12 novembre
2015 et 24 mars 2016 philippe je
t'envoie pas une photo dédicacée midi
photo db alors ya une deuxième lettre
aussi c'est une carte postale berry qui
a gagné un week end au ski gaza tpm paix
qui nous a gentiment envoyé une carte
postale de ses vacances voilà regarder
auquel il a beaucoup de neige et du
soleil sur les traces de cyril et ses
chroniqueurs voilà il ya aussi il ya un
mec qui s'appelle wilfried regarder la
lettre est folle wilfrid j'aime votre
émission qui est gay divertissement et
où surtout souriante sur est il possible
de pêcher au kenya à gaza après 0,6
d'avancé dans les points dans l'espoir
d'avoir une réponse merci oui mais si
c'est une vraie blonde elle est
magnifique et est pire pour avoir et
pourrait y avoir le numéro le 06
d'agathe pseudo proulx et 2 caroline
ithurbide voilà
vous êtes des deux dernières lettres à
mes chéris d'un retraité qui m'a écrit
mais elle est magique est tombé sur une
lettre très drôle castres le 5 mars 2018
ne la mettait pas qu'est ce qu'on attend
pour vous [ __ ] dehors pourriture vous
qui regardez l'émission jusqu'à 21h20 je
vous ai et vous êtes affreux savard
était en colère mais alors lui le gars
qui écrit ça moi perso je le kiffe mais
oui voilà s'il veut venir à jour dans
l'émission franchement en plus je pense
qu'il est de la famille t-il verdel s'il
veut venir
c'est avec plaisir et je lui fais de
gros bisous j'espère qu'il va venir
recevoir
voilà l'autre depuis tout à l'heure
c'est devenu le cliché isabelle
morini-bosc campagne à venir son plateau
un bien sûr c'est que l'erreur soit pour
être là un truc brèche sur qui les idées
d'arc à genou droit je suis désolé quoi
je vous crois vous avez vu tout à
l'heure on a vu la lettre de wilfrid qui
voulait le numéro de tout le monde ouais
mais bon on a retrouvé son portable il
au téléphone
wilfred wilfrid tu es là ok mais on
rappellera une erreur mon n'a pas encore
levé un fluide série wxa wilfried
wilfried oui ouais ça va t'en vas tu
veux pécho kelly oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu veux pechoux agathe oui d'accord tu
vas pécho cavani des turbines aussi tu
veux mais sur mathieu non les cafés
meilleur coût or depuis ce temps c'est
toi pendant de me vanter je connais mes
qualités mes faiblesses mama bâ calme
toi arrête un peureux dix ans la
consommation wilfried tu viens nous voir
quand tu veux je te ferai pas je te
présenterait tout le monde d'accord - us
reid et mais ok y'a pas de soucis mais
il faut que je trouve un moyen de
locomotion pour mon cas il faut que le
droit la moyenne de l'autre motion avec
loupé j28 yade entendu puisque eux mêmes
sur carcassonne
tu fais quoi dans la d1000 fidh thabet
musique
merci oui je sais qu'il ya le très bon
aller sur paris mais il est pas donné
pas de voiture pour me rendre jusqu'à la
gare chez moi c'est tout
on va trouver ça n'inquiète pas je vais
te trouvais ça on va organiser ça
d'accord mon chéri merci en tout cas pas
dans la téléphonie sans problème bon je
te fais venir vendredi prochain au caire
a laissé prendre à une fois je devais
venir allez salut je t'embrasse
renchérit c'est au masters
[Applaudissements]